PRESIDENT ASSAD AT HIS
DICTATORIAL REGIME AT ANY
MOMENT.
FIRST WE START WITH A VERY
IMPORTANT OPENING NEWS.
MONOLOGUE.
IT'S BENEFICIALLY 328 DAYS SINCE
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER WAS APPOINTED TO
INVESTIGATE SO-CALLED RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE INTO OUR ELECTIONS.
TONIGHT WE ARE STILL ASKING THE
QUESTION, WHERE IS ANY EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION?
SHOW US.
NOTHING SO FAR.
NOT A WHIFF.
NO EVIDENCE.
INSTEAD OF CONCRETE FACTS,
INFORMATION SURROUNDINGS
RUSSIA'S ILLICIT ACTIONS, WE NOW
HAVE A RUNAWAY INVESTIGATION
SPINNING OUT OF CONTROL LED BY
MUELLER AND HIS MERRY BAND OF
TRUMP-HATING DEEP ESTATE
SYCOPHANTS.
WE HAVE GONE OVER YEARS-OLD
PAYMENTS FROM UKRAINE TO AN
INVESTIGATION INTO ALLEGED
AFFAIRS BETWEEN TRUMP AND STORMY
DANIELS.
TODAY WE ARE LEARNING FROM
REPORTS THAT FBI AGENTS DURING
THE COHEN RAID, THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR INFORMATION ABOUT PAYMENTS
MADE TO A FORMER "PLAYBOY"
PLAYMATE KAREN MCDOUGAL.
DOES ANYONE BELIEVE THAT A PORN
STAR AND A FORMER "PLAYBOY"
PLAYMATE, THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
SHED ANY LIGHT ON POTENTIAL
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA?
THE ANSWER IS OF COURSE NOT.
ROBERT MUELLER HAS OFFICIALLY
GONE ROGUE AND DECLARED WAR
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, STORMY
DANIELS, CNN WILL BE SO PROUD.
THEY ARE NOW COOPERATING WITH
ROBERT MUELLER AND HIS PROBE.
THIS ROGUE ACTIVITY FROM MUELLER
IS NOTHING NEW.
REMEMBER IN MARCH, FORMER TRUMP
POLITICAL ADVISOR SAM LUNDBERG
SAID MUELLER WAS SEEKING
INFORMATION REGARDING MICHAEL
COHEN'S PAYMENTS, YOU GOT IT, TO
STORMY DANIELS.
SO MUCH FOR RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
SO MUCH FOR RUSSIAN INTERFERENC
INTERFERENCE.
>> DID MUELLER'S FOLKS ASK
ANYTHING ABOUT PAYMENTS TO
WOMEN?
>> THEY ASKED IF I HAD HEARD
ANYTHING ABOUT IT AT MY ANSWER
IS I NEVER HAVE.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: SADLY, TONIGHT WHAT
IS HAPPENING IS MUELLER'S
RUNAWAY TRAIN OF AN
INVESTIGATION IS SOMETHING WE
HAVE NOW BEEN WARNING YOU ABOUT
FOR OVER A YEAR.
I HAVE TOLD YOU THERE ARE FIVE
FORCES ACTIVELY WORKING AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY HAVE FROM THE BEGINNING.
IT'S YOUR CORRUPT MEDIA, THE
CORRUPT DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WEAK ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS,
NEVER TRUMP-ERS.
AND WHAT WE DESCRIBE AS THE DEEP
STATE.
TONIGHT YOU HAVE THOSE FORCES
WORKING TOGETHER TO MALIGN THE
PRESIDENT YOU ELECTED.
WE DID SOME DIGGING.
REPORTS YOU'VE BEEN HEARING
ABOUT THE INNER WORKINGS OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
THEY INCLUDE A LOT OF ANONYMOUS
SOURCES.
IN FACT, SOME OF THESE REPORTS
ARE TOTALLY BASED ON ANONYMOUS
SOURCING.
WHO ARE ALL OF THESE ANONYMOUS
PEOPLE FEEDING ALL THIS
INFORMATION TO THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE LIBERAL MEDIA?
COULD IT BE THAT MUELLER'S TEAM
IS ACTUALLY COORDINATING WITH
THE LIBERAL MEDIA?
TURNING PUBLIC OPINION AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
THAT HELPS THEIR CASE.
MAYBE MUELLER'S OFFICE IN THEIR
EMAILS, MAYBE THEY WILL GET
RATED IN THE PREDAWN HOURS.
IF YOU WILL SEE THAT HAPPEN.
CLEARLY THEY CORRUPT MEDIA AND
MUELLER, KNOWING THERE IS NO
COLLUSION, NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION, IF I HAD IT, WE WOULD
KNOW IT, THEY ARE HOPING
PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTUALLY FIRES
MUELLER.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, LIKE SARAH
SANDERS SAID TODAY, THE
PRESIDENT DOES HAVE ACTUALLY THE
LEGAL RIGHT TO FIRE MUELLER.
WE KNOW IF THE PRESIDENT DOES,
IMAGINE THE POLITICAL OUTCRY,
WHAT IT WOULD BE LIKE.
IT WOULD BE MASSIVE.
THIS IS LIKELY EXACTLY WHAT MANY
IN THESE FIVE FORCES WANTS
SPARK THE HUMILIATING END OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY THAT WE THE
PEOPLE VOTED FOR.
AFTER ALL, THAT'S BEEN THEIR
GOAL FROM THE GET-GO.
WE HAVE ALWAYS KNOWN THAT.
IN THEIR MINDS, THIS WOULD SET
PRESIDENT TRUMP UP TO BE
IMPEACHED.
THE SAD TRUTH TONIGHT AS WELL
MUELLER IS ON THIS WITCH HUNT
FISHING EXPEDITION, IT'S
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT IF TRUMP
FIRES MUELLER, SADLY NOTHING
WILL GO AWAY.
THE TRUTH IS IT WILL ONLY GET
WORSE.
IT WILL ONLY GET LOUDER.
IT WILL ONLY BE MORE DIVIDED.
NOTHING WILL GET DONE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER, IT APPEARS,
HOW ROGUE ROBERT MUELLER IS.
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT HE DID WITH
"WHITEY" BULGER IN BOSTON.
TWO DIED IN JAIL BECAUSE OF THE
FBI INFORMANT IN HIS OFFICE
WORKING WITH MUELLER AND HIS
TEAM.
AFTER TWO DIED, THERE WAS OVER
$100 MILLION PAID OUT IN THAT
CASE.
DOESN'T SEEM TO MATTER TO
ANYBODY IN THE LIBERAL MEDIA
THAT MUELLER'S PITBULL, AS
DESCRIBED BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," ANDREW
WEISSMANN, THAT HE WAS INVOLVED
IN TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR JOBS, THEIR CAREERS
AT ARTHUR ANDERSEN ACCOUNTING.
DOESN'T MATTER AT ALL.
ANDREW WEISSMANN 9-0B ARE AND
HOW OFTEN DOES NOT HAPPEN?
IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT FOUR
MERRILL EXECUTIVES WENT TO JAIL
FOR A YEAR AND THAT THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS
OVERTURNED THEIR CONVICTIONS.
DOESN'T SEEM TO MATTER THE
COURTS HAVE EXCORIATED MUELLER'S
PITBULL FOR WITHHOLDING
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT MUELLER'S
TEAM ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY DONATED
MONEY TO OBAMA, HILLARY, AND THE
DNC.
AFTER ALL, WHY WOULD ROBERT
MUELLER HIRE A GUY LIKE ANDREW
WEISSMANN WITHOUT ATROCIOUS
TRACK RECORD?
WHY WAS HE EVER A POINT?
THE ANSWER IS IT WAS A FISHING
EXPEDITION, AND IT WAS AN EFFORT
TO GET TRUMP FROM THE BEGINNING.
NOW WE ARE STUCK WITH A NEVER
ENDING, WHAT SEEMS TO BE OUT OF
CONTROL INVESTIGATION.
MARK LIVE IN, HAD IT.
HE IS CALLING FOR ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I WANT TO MAKE A POINT.
NOT INTENDED TO BE PROVOCATIVE
OR CONTROVERSIAL.
IT WILL DESTROY A 30-YEAR
FRIENDSHIP BUT I REALLY DO THINK
IT'S TIME FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO STEP ASIDE.
THE BUCK STOPS ON THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S DESK.
EVEN IF HE RECUSE HIMSELF, AS HE
DID, THIS IS NOT THE RUSSIA
MATTER.
>> Sean: ONLY SAVE RATES FOR
DRUG DEALERS AND CRIMINALS,
ORGANIZED CRIME FROM POTENTIAL
TERRORIST.
APPARENTLY NOT.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, SESSIONS'
RECUSAL, THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
NOW ROGUE SPECIAL COUNSEL BY ROD
ROSENSTEIN WHO IS OUT OF CONTROL
HIMSELF AND CONFLICTED, WHY HE
DIDN'T HAVE TO RECUSE IS ANOTHER
QUESTION.
IT'S A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF WHAT I
HAVE BEEN WARNING ABOUT.
A TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT'S LONGTIME
PERSONAL ATTORNEY MICHAEL HAD
HIS HOME, HIS HOTEL, AND OF
COURSE HIS OFFICE RATED BY THE
FBI.
OVER $130,000 PAYMENT AS THE
PERSONAL ATTORNEY OF
DONALD TRUMP TO STORMY DANIELS.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE NOT
UNDERSTANDING IS WHEN THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL RIDES THE
OFFICES OF THE PRESIDENT'S
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAS
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAC
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAL
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAY
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAB
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAC
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAK
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAD
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAO
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAR
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAH
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAS
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAW
PRIVATE ATTORNEY, MUELLER IS BAY
INTO EVERY SINGLE TROUT BUSINESS
DEAL SINCE MICHAEL COHEN'S
WORK WITH DONALD TRUMP.
DO YOU WANT TO TAKE BETS ON WHAT
MUELLER AND WEISSMANN ARE
LOOKING FOR?
I HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA.
IT'S AN UNPRECEDENTED ABUSE OF
POWER.
HE NEEDS TO BE COUNTERED
IMMEDIATELY.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD ADD TO HIS
TEAM OF TOP-NOTCH LAWYERS A
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM, TOP-NOTCH
COMMUNICATIONS SKILLS AND
FRANKLY THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
IMMEDIATELY START ADVANCING THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHO ROBERT MUELLER
IS, WHAT HIS MANDATE WAS, HOW
FAR BEYOND HIS MANDATE HE IS,
AND ABOUT HIS ENTIRE TEAM OF
DEMOCRATIC DONORS.
FRANKLY, ANY NEGOTIATIONS THAT
WERE GOING ON WITH THE PRESIDENT
TALKING TO ROBERT MUELLER, THAT
SHOULD PROBABLY LIKELY END IF IT
HASN'T ALREADY.
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS LEGAL TEAM
SHOULD BE PREPARING TO TAKE THIS
ALL THE WAY TO THE UNITED STATES
APPEAR IN COURT.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE TONIGHT.
IT'S TIME TO INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATORS, AS WE HAVE BEEN
DOING.
WE'VE GOT TO INVESTIGATE HIS
TEAM OF PARTISAN WITCH HUNTERS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO OVERTURN A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT.
IF YOU VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP,
YOU BETTER GET BUCKLED UP
BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO BE A
ROUGH RIDE.
THEY SHOULD PROBABLY REMIND
PEOPLE DAILY THAT IT APPEARS
THERE IS NO LONGER EQUAL
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
LET ME GIVE YOU A CASE IN POINT.
START WITH HILLARY CLINTON.
CLEARLY SHE IS GUILTY.
INCONTROVERTIBLE EVIDENCE.
MULTIPLE FELONIES.
HIS HANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, DESTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME, TRY
DELETING 33,000 SUBPOENAED
EMAILS, ACID WASHING YOUR HARD
DRIVE, DESTROYING YOUR
CELL PHONE WITH HAMMERS.
WAS HER HOME RATED?
WAS HER LAWYER'S HOME RATED?
NO CHANCE.
WHAT ABOUT JAMES COMEY?
BRUCE OHR?
PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE.
ONE ABOUT SUSAN RICE?
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THE FOREIGN
NATIONAL THAT FUSION GPS HIRED
AND FUNNELED THE MONEY AND A
FOREIGN NATIONAL GOT RUSSIAN
LIES.
WHAT ABOUT, WHO LIED TO THE FISA
COURT JUDGES?
YOU CAN SEE ON THE SIDE OF YOUR
SCREEN, THERE REALLY AREN'T ANY
ANTI-TRUMP OFFICIALS OR ENTITIES
WHO HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO ANY OF
THESE TACTICS, NONE.
WE KNOW HILLARY CLINTON DID
COMMIT FELONIES.
HOW CAN IT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE FAITH IN THEIR JUSTICE
SYSTEM TONIGHT?
ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATING PRESIDENT TRUMP,
APPARENTLY DID A 20 MINUTE
SPEECH ON SKYPE TO THE UKRAINE
FOR 150 GRAND FROM A UKRAINIAN
NATIONAL PAID GOOD MONEY IF YOU
CAN MAKE IT.
GUESS WHAT.
THAT SAME UKRAINIAN NATIONAL
GAVE THE CLINTONS $13 MILLION.
NO OUTRAGE, NO COVERAGE FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
TALK ABOUT HYPOCRISY.
TODAY THE FBI NOTIFIED JUDICIAL
WATCH.
TOM FITTON IS ON THE SHOW A LOT.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE THREE LONG
YEARS TO TURN OVER REQUESTS FOR
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
ANTI-TRUMP FBI AGENTS PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE.
CAN YOU SAY TWO-TIERED JUSTICE
SYSTEM?
A NOTORIOUS HIGH-RANKING SOVIET
OFFICIALS SAID SHOW ME THE MAN.
I WILL FIND YOU THE CRIME.
SOUND FAMILIAR TO MUELLER'S
NEVER ENDING INVESTIGATION WAY
BEYOND THIS MANDATE.
THIS CONCEPT IS WHOLLY
UN-AMERICAN.
IT'S VERY DANGEROUS TO OUR
SYSTEM.
DANGEROUS TO THE CONSTITUTION IF
YOU BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF LAW.
TONIGHT I AM SAYING GAME ON.
IF SOMEBODY HITS YOU, IT'S TIME
TO FIGHT BACK.
NEEDS TO COME TO AN END
MICROGRAPH TO TURN OUR ATTENTION
TO THE MEDIA TONIGHT.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, THE DESTROY
TRUMP MEDIA ARE SALIVATING.
THEY ARE SO HOPEFUL THAT THERE
LYING NARRATIVE WILL BE COVERED
UP BY STORMY DANIELS WITH THE
NEWS REGARDING MICHAEL COHEN.
ONE UNHINGED JOURNALIST'S APRIL
RYAN.
SHE HAS LITERALLY TAKEN TRUMP
HATRED TO A WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
LISTEN TO WHAT SHE ASKED SARAH
SANDERS EARLIER TODAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING.
YOU WON'T BELIEVE IT.
>> WITH ALL OF THIS TURMOIL,
PARTICULARLY THIS LAST WEEK, HAS
THE PRESIDENT HAD IN THE TIME
THOUGHT ABOUT STEPPING DOWN
BEFORE OR NOW?
>> NO, AND I THINK THAT'S AN
ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS QUESTION.
WE ARE MOVING ON.
>> Sean: REALLY, APRIL?
THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE TIME TO
PUSH YOUR INNER POLITICAL
FANTASIES?
I'M SURE YOUR BOSS IS REALLY
PROUD OF YOU.
WILL BRING YOU MORE EXAMPLES
LATER BUT WE ARE MONITORING THE
SITUATION GOING ON IN SYRIA.
THE PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED TO
RESPOND WITH FORCE TO THE RECENT
GAS ATTACKS THAT TOOK PLACE
THERE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A MAN OF HIS
WORD.
IS THE UNITED STATES SUPPOSED TO
STAND BY AND WATCH ASSAD USING
CHEMICAL WEAPONS ON MEN, WOMEN,
AND CHILDREN?
SHOULD IT GO UNANSWERED?
SADLY THE SAME CANNOT BE SAID
FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN HE WAS
ON THE WORLD STAGE.
HE DREW A LINE IN THE SAND.
YOU MIGHT'VE FORGOTTEN.
HE DID NOTHING.
>> WE HAVE COMMUNICATED IN NO
UNCERTAIN TERMS WITH EVERY
PLAYER IN THE REGION THAT THAT'S
A REDLINE FOR US.
AND THEY WOULD BE ENORMOUS
CONSEQUENCES IF WE START SEEING
MOVEMENT ON THE CHEMICAL WEAPONS
FRONT OR THE USE OF CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
THAT WOULD CHANGE MY
CALCULATIONS.
SIGNIFICANTLY.
>> Sean: AFTER ASSAD CROSSED
THE LINE AND CONTINUED TO GATHER
HIS OWN PEOPLE, THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION STRUCK A DEAL.
JOHN KERRY TOLD US 100% OF THOSE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS WERE GOING TO
BE REMOVED FROM SYRIA.
THEN THEY DECLARED DIPLOMATIC
VICTORY.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER.
>> WE WERE ABLE TO FIND A
SOLUTION THAT ACTUALLY REMOVED
THE CHEMICAL WEAPONS THAT WERE
KNOWN FROM SYRIA IN A WAY THAT
THE USE OF FORCE WOULD NEVER
HAVE ACCOMPLISHED.
>> RUSSIA HAS BEEN CONSTRUCTIVE
IN HELPING TO REMOVE 100% OF THE
DECLARED CHEMICAL WEAPONS FROM
SYRIA.
THAT WAS IN AGREEMENT WE MADE
MONTHS AGO AND IT NEVER FALTERED
EVEN IN THESE MOMENTS OF
CONFLICT.
>> PEOPLE CRITICIZED US FOR NOT
LAUNCHING MISSILES AGAINST ASSAD
BUT KEEP IN MIND WHY WE DIDN'T.
WE DIDN'T BECAUSE THEY GOT RID
OF THE CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT.
>> Sean: WISHFUL THINKING OR
WILLFUL IGNORANCE?
EITHER WAY, EVEN FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE UNDER
BILL CLINTON MADELEINE ALBRIGHT
WAS CALLING OUT OBAMA'S
MIDDLE EAST FAILURE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DONALD TRUMP SAYS THIS IS
BARACK OBAMA'S FAULT BECAUSE THE
FIRST TIME THIS HAPPENED, BARACK
OBAMA DO NOT USE MILITARY ACTION
AGAINST ASSAD'S REGIME.
DO YOU THINK HE'S RIGHT?
>> I DON'T.
BARACK OBAMA DID PUT DOWN A
REDLINE, AND I PERSONALLY WISH
WE HAD FOLLOWED THROUGH ON IT.
>> Sean: CAN AMERICA STAND BY
AS INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN ARE BEING GASSED?
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN?
I AM NOT TALKING ABOUT ANYWAY
AND INVASION OF ANY KIND BUT
ASSAD, THOSE WEAPONS HAVE TO BE
REMOVED.
WHEN AMERICA'S PROMISES ARE
EMPTY AND ITS LEADERS ARE WEAK
AND INEFFECTIVE LIKE OBAMA, WE
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
PAYOFFS, DEATH, DESTRUCTION.
THE WORLD BECOMES LESS SAFE.
WE HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS TONIGHT
THAT YOU PROBABLY WON'T HEAR
ABOUT THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
DONALD TRUMP STRIKES AGAIN.
AFTER WEEKS OF TOUGH TALKS AND
PRODUCTIONS THAT CHINA IS NEVER
GOING TO NEGOTIATE ON TRADE, THE
PRESIDENT OF CHINA HAS ANNOUNCED
HIS COUNTRY PLANS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER CERTAIN
TARIFFS ON AUTOMOBILES WHICH IS
GOOD FOR AMERICAN WORKERS, AND
THAT THEY WOULD BE WORKING
TOWARDS PRESERVING INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY RIGHTS OF AMERICANS
WHICH IS ANOTHER GOOD THING.
TWO KEY CONCESSIONS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS SEEKING.
GOOD NEWS FOR AMERICAN BUSINESS
AND OUR AUTO INDUSTRY.
EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT
REACHED OUT TO THE PRESIDENT OF
CHINA ON TWITTER.
"VERY THANKFUL FOR PRESIDENT XI
OF CHINA'S KIND WORDS ON TARIFFS
AND AUTOMOBILE BARRIERS.
ALSO, HIS ENLIGHTENMENT ON
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AND
TECHNOLOGY TRANSFERS.
WE WILL MAKE GREAT PROGRESS
TOGETHER!"
ALSO TONIGHT THE FACEBOOK CEO